now outline the way this is part be
right how we going for time okay outline
the ways in which database systems are
central to the function of Worldport
okay now you need to mention well why
databases why would they use a database
well for a very good reason because the
data is very highly structured they know
the same kinds of themes that all of the
packages and they can know with a higher
degree of consistency right so that's
what we mean by highly structured okay
we know a destination we know the source
we know that and so on and so on so
these here I'm actually referring to i'm
using my previous answer i'm using the
databases from here right as the
framework my skeleton for my answer to
Part B okay so if you didn't know the
database as well you invariably struggle
in puppy but even if you got that wrong
you still could have worked them out
from the article okay right so I was
looking for a specific mission of those
databases right part see how we going
over the page explain ways in which this
company currently uses decision support
systems that's the first bit and how
could they further improve the
efficiency with new decision support
systems okay so some of you had some
trouble with this because you mixed up
what were the decisions for systems and
what were people right as a person I'm
not a decision support system on a
person right so decision support systems
are electronic systems which help the
humans right so what's already there I'd
probably say the two that I thought of
and were the zip code recognition system
right takes up photo and there's a
decision that has to be made right what
zip code it's a sec right so a system is
brought in to automatically do that
that's where the dss is right now you
can probably also say that that path
working out how do I get from A to B the
plane where I arrived and the plane
where I'm going to depart you probably
could say there's a decision support
system there to work out the most
efficient path because it's not
one part how do you know that remember
there's a point in the article it talks
to this how do we know that there's not
just one way to get from plan a to play
beat is a word in the article.really
find it for them that a movie should be
on the second page fig even I've lost it
right there in the middle actually okay
if you're looking and I'll draw your
take them to other things as well um one
other thing here in the page right look
at this paragraph here so it's half a
paragraph 1 2 3 at the bottom of that
the last sentence it says the system has
a 20-percent redundancy what is
redundancy me redundancy in this context
that's right something isn't vital so or
something is repeated so in this system
what that means is okay there's multiple
paths that could work if one path breaks
down it just it's not like I know all
the packages can't go through they'll
just go through a different part now on
that note well I'm well I've got the
article here i'm showing it to you have
a look at those three paragraphs that
one two three okay those are the only
paragraphs you needed to draw your data
flow diagram all the rest this stuff
have nothing to do with it okay and you
know it says because as containers are
unloaded right that's how it starts and
then that third paragraph says the
entire sorting process from unloading to
reloading takes about blood on the block
so you can see it starts and then it
finishes so anyway if you're frustrated
at the article was long you can find all
the right information it was long but
you had to be able to identify where's
the right spot okay so one the SS for
zip code recognition to for the conveyor
solid system working out of my part 3
probably for the automatic way of those
completed you LDS right that's not
automatically ok now where could you add
some DSS's in there right well probably
the weather start
right there people who are employed to
do that maybe you could have a system
and expert system introduced for that
right now if you said expert system but
you didn't tell me well what's the
Exorcist thing going to do I kind of war
marks because it doesn't demonstrate
understanding it demonstrates ability to
copy notes which is helpful but not
enough to actually reward wise right I'm
you met you might also have mentioned
that the HR staff Human Resources stuff
the ones who work out our we're going to
have to employ more people here less
people here that process maybe it could
be done automatically because a lot of
that it's sort of you know there's
patterns that can be determined by an
artificial neural network that kind of
thing right and there's more answers
here I think you can bring those okay
yes yeah is the right word let's get our
special methyl issues right now again
for marks for max tends to be a typical
I tend to think of for if I can think of
at least eight I can't remember how many
we worked out in this sketch but you had
to have the pluses and the minuses right
again change your nature of work was a
really free easy one which went both
ways is a plus and a minus so it's easy
to mention that one one that was
forgotten I thought was a really cool
one right is that without Worldport
without this whole facility you really
can't do international commerce with the
kind of efficiency that's possible today
that you can just order something online
and it will come in a reasonable amount
of time right its facilities like
Worldport which make that possible okay
so I think it's pretty emission pretty
amazing now let's have a look at this
one high degree of accuracy now again
I'm pointing at this one because it's a
positive I think it's a positive some
people say it was a negative they said
this is crazy it's dangerous robots are
doing everything they're going to make
so many mistakes well let's think about
how many mistakes they're making cuz the
article said sir it says in the that
article that that power off there one
two three fourth paragraph down I'm
99.999 four percent accuracy rate so
point zero zero zero six percent
mistake now if you call that as Saudi
did a really high prevalence of errors
then you have really crazy high
standards if I made point zero zero zero
six percent of errors unlike say no math
exams and I did I feel like I you know
I'm Stacy law okay that's an amazing
level of accuracy so accuracy really
should be applause okay really should
have it applies if you said it was a
negative you needed to do some pretty
fancy justified work to say yes this is
it incredibly inaccurate system okay if
you're justified i mighta give it to you
but I think anyone was able to prove it
substantially okay um let's look at some
of the negatives um now the ergonomics
risks that was a good one I think that
half of you mentioned that one it's very
good because this continual looking at
screens that's an Emma config enormous
problem right so that's an easy one to
pick up in fact it often comes up but
you need to say look it's an a great
risk because of the screens you couldn't
just say there's increased risk of
economics right does that make sense can
you see if I just say that it's just
like well I'm just copied that off my
notes which say ergonomics is an issue
sometimes right you have to relate that
to the question yeah okay um yeah I
think I think most of you got the rest
of that that's quite 10